RIght now we're standing in line for the Blumhouse attraction here at Halloween Horror Nights.
Last year we did The Purge maze which was fun,
but this year they've added the entire Blumhouse lineup, so we've got:
a new contender in Happy Death Day,
Sinister,
Insidious I think is a different maze,
and all of the Blumhouse properties mixed into one.
It's a mixtape. It's very high quality music.
I'm giving them out, but only a couple people will get the limited edition Claude Gnome edition.
Who are you going to be giving them out to?
The Purge people.
Search Claude Gnome on YouTube.
And then your life will be good.
You guys get to go first.
Ashes, ashes, we all fall down...
Ring around the rosie...
Pocket full of poseys.
Ashes. Ashes.
We all fall down.
This is my boyfriend.
You want it?
Subscribe to Claude Gnome.
That's the real one!
Mixtape?
Oh, he actually took it!
He actually!
He took his mixtape.
We did the Blumhouse thing.
It really wasn't all the Blumhouse movies, but it was just those three that I listed.
Happy Death Day, The Purge and Sinister.
The best one was probably The Purge section.
The Happy Death Day one was a little bit disappointing.
I handed it to him. He saw how good the artwork was on it.
And he said, "this looks like high quality music,"
so he took it.
Did you say anything to him?
I said bruh, checkout my mixtape!
We did the Blumhouse one, now we're in line for just the Insidious one.
So I'm here, there are a lot of horror fans here, I'm assuming at Halloween Horror Nights.
So I figure, might as well do some marketing while I'm here.
OK, I couldn't get it to stick to that pole,
But them some people saw me trying to do it and asked me what I was doing,
so then I handed out a bunch of them.
So I think I'm doing good in the marketing department right now.
Ayyyyyy!!!!
Never do that again.
I really liked the Purge, but the Happy Death Day was really disappointing.
Basically all they did was have the baby mask everywhere and they didn't really do anything with the movie.
What was your favorite part of the Blumhouse maze?
When they took my mixtape.
That's my favorite guy.
He sees you.
Don't you dare!!
This entity is very powerful.
The elevator's gonna take a while.
OMG it's real.
Held with the tortured soul.
DON'T YOU DARE!!
No one wanted my mixtape.
So we did the Insidious one.
It was shorter than the Blumhouse one.
And my favorite guy was only in it once, but what they did have was pretty cool.
The last 3 seconds when that guy almost hit me in the face, that was pretty scary.
Oh, when she walked up and screamed in my face?
That was really terrifying, it was like flashbacks of my mother.
They didn't take my mixtape.